وبدأنا الجولة الأولى من المرحلة الثانية
عدو ليلي إلى طاجيكستان اذهب إليه
العقبة التالية تمر بالضبط
انفجار على القطعة رقم 2 1 الدائرة الحنية
كاشير لا رينتا الرقص avtovo
لديك من كابل تان تان كازاخستان
أخذت فرصة
من رماد اليابان الأردن دورال نعم و ذ
يتم إجراء السحب الأول لنا
الإضاءة المستمرة من لحظة إلى
إعدام أطلق النار ولدينا
فجوة الإثارة ونائب الرئيس على يد الثانية
عاش مرحلة العدو الليلي هناك في بينزا
يحتوي الملف على ذراع جمهورية طاجيكستان
اختلط في منزله غرفته على حد سواء
مشروبات اللحية الصفراء
وقبضت على الرجل
فريق هات جاك ستان معنا على ميتا
هذا الكائن كله بدون مجلد معدني و
بارك ديلوكس
لفات دير حيث INFA منها أيضا بالمناسبة
جمهورية معنا قذائف الهاون والنسور
أفضل فريق مع